my morning must reads from Barry
Ritholtz who's riding in Bloomberg View
taking a look at what we all missed with
apple and then what we all missed again
today with Deutsche Bank he writes how
is it even remotely possible that wall
street analysts have no idea was the
biggest company in the world is doing
Neil Dada I know that you're not a stock
picker you're a macro guy but you know
Barry Ritholtz writes about you know the
biases that there's a bullish bias until
too late and then there's a bearish bias
until too late and do you feel do you
feel like you have these as well you get
attached to a certain narrative about
the economy and then you got to stick
with it I think for forecasting it's
important for people to focus on the
batting average so to speak right I mean
typically I mean there's actually
academic research that shows you know
forecasters that get one big call right
again to be wrong about everything else
I just think that's I mean think about
it that way it's it you know your trick
is never get anything right well I mean
I think it's important for castings
about weighing a range of probable
outcomes of them picking your battles
with the consensus wisely get one one
big thing right the John Paulson yeah or
or I mean in the economics arena I mean
you know the name is I mean nouriel
roubini I mean you know look I mean you
know Tom will tell you I was pretty
cautious on the US a couple years ago
but you know you have to switch as the
data changes yeah you know I there's
always going to be critics and we also
have that we have a narrative bite us
Jamie Metzel do you get attached to
certain you know writers also get
attached to certain narratives as well
right yeah well you do but the part of
being the be a thoughtful person in any
field you need to have your own views
and your own hypotheses and then
constantly bringing in data and making
your best assessments and I hope that
all of us can have more than one thing
right over the course of our lifetimes
but but that's whether it's what we're
doing here that's why people are
watching Bloomberg is that we're
challenging our narratives every day and
that's the way thoughtful we had mark
father on earlier this week we said
economist since 2001 have been right
twelve point seven percent of the time
these 12 points outing is 12.8